hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is the
summer 2015 edition in this edition our
articles on wallasey Island wild coast
clean up local volunteer award a
kaleidoscope of butterflies the
district's superheroes Swain park open
air cinema and much more but we'll start
with details of the latest wild woods
day crowds go wild in woods accompanied
by a lot of super photograph showing
lots of activities that the people did
on the day hottie Woods was packed with
over 4,000 visitors as Rochford District
Council hosted its most successful wild
woods day yet the event sponsored by
fusion lifestyle celebrated its 12th
year with celebrity appearances from
titan the robot and TV chef Rob Kennedy
who was cooking up a storm demonstrating
how to use up your leftovers for
delicious nutritious meals in minutes
visitors were also treated to a range of
creative and adventurous activities in
the ancient woods from tree climbing by
the council's woodlands team to fencing
lessons from olympian james beavers
along with this there were the return of
the old favorites the climbing wall
martial arts classes and the pop-up
market selling recycled and up cycled
goods art and fresh local produce this
year also featured a special performance
compos mentis presented by quali range
all stars which captivated audiences and
had the children laughing from start to
finish it was the busiest wildwoods day
the council is ever organized it also
acted as a curtain raiser to a busy year
for the new chairman of the council
counselor mrs. Heather Glynn she said I
so enjoyed myself the whole day was
absolutely fantastic
it's so nice to see family is coming to
hockley woods to enjoy the event and see
the stunning surroundings wild woods day
is always a success but this year we
seem to have outdone ourselves each year
it gets bigger and busier and I hope
that everyone who came along enjoyed
themselves business section business
diary dates the economic development
team is continuing to provide local
businesses with advice and support
through offering a one-to-one support or
service and hosting various events in
2015 the team have committed to
providing 11 events of which 5 have
already taken place and have been
extremely successful these business
events are an excellent resource for our
business community and we are really
encouraged to see businesses engage with
these events do you want to keep updated
on business news the Rockford business
network was set up in 2009 as a key
information and mailing service between
the council and local businesses by
joining this free network you will have
access to quarterly newsletters
detailing events and initiatives that
affect local businesses regular emails
that include local and national
information including opportunities for
grants and funding a support structure
for local businesses to connect with
each other booking details for our
business events and other local events
if you are interested in joining this
network please email business at
Rochford govt UK dates for the diary
September the 16th business briefing
marketing and social media October the
15th skills summit showcasing training
apprenticeships and funding November the
4th business summit engage with leaders
and have your voice heard November the
18th business briefing creating a vision
January the 20th business briefing
marketing and social media to find out
more about these events and to see what
other support services the economic
development team offer
please go to ww a govt UK forward slash
business local business gets boost from
council local businesswoman may smart
really does have something to celebrate
as a health food business wins
prestigious national awards with support
from Rochford district councils economic
development team beating off some very
well-known supermarket giants may won
first prize for her rosary and oil and
olive oil [ __ ] acheté in the bread
category at this year's free from food
awards with one of the judges commenting
great for restaurants excellent taste
and texture may contacted Rochford
district council when she first started
smart eats and treats for business
support the economic development team an
environmental health team have provided
advice and support over the last year
may said i was so surprised at the
support i received from Rochford
district council and they really helped
me to continue to pursue my business
goals it can be quite isolating when
running a business from home by yourself
and Rochford district council always
gave me encouragement to keep going i
was unaware of this vital service which
they can offer to businesses like mine
and i would recommend all local
businesses to get in contact with the
economic development team they have a
welfare information which has really
helped me out and i'm sure that others
will find it just as useful as I did and
councillor Mike steptoe portfolio holder
for enterprise said it's always
heartening to hear positive stories from
our small local businesses I would urge
all of our local businesses to utilize
our free business support service and
more information can be found at may
smarts website at wwlp.com LG free or
one word coach UK for more information
about the support available for local
businesses please contact the economic
development team at business at Rochford
gov qk or you can call them 0170 23 180
Expo annual sports awards this is your
chance to submit nominations for the
annual Rochford and castlepoint sports
awards 2015 sponsored by fusion
lifestyle all nominees must either live
within the Rochford district or borough
of council Castle Point or be a current
and competing or participating member of
a sports club based within either area
or go to school in either area in the
case of sports club of the year the club
must be based within the Rockford
district or borough of Castle Point and
these are the categories sports
personality of the year sponsored by
Wells legal solicitors services to sport
/ respect sponsored by the co-operative
funeralcare disability sports
personality of the year sponsored by
waters and Stanton limited sports club
of the year sponsored by pinnacle PSG
young sports personality of the year
sponsored by southend united community
and educational trust and school of the
year sponsored by affinity 1777 those
candidates who are shortlisted for
awards will be invited to the award
ceremony which will take place on the
evening of the 12th November 2015 at the
mill arts & Events Center in rayleigh
winners in each category will receive an
engraved trophy shield certificate and
check for a hundred pounds the form asks
for details of the nominee details of
the person nominating and the reason for
the nomination if you have difficulty
completing a form please call the
council and help will be available it's
time now for some community news and B
we begin with the wild coast clean up at
wallasey Island watford District Council
were recently joined by staff from
mcdonalds Southend to clean up the
coastline at wallasey Island where a
nature reserve is being created by the
rspb the volunteers picked up more than
20
bags of rubbish and some larger items
that had been washed up on the seawall
Leslie a sea of Rochford District
Council's street scene team said it was
fantastic to clean up the seawall to
help protect the environment we also
spotted some of the wildlife including
an adder and a rare Brown European hair
and if you would like advice or support
with arranging a litter pic please
contact the recycling team on 0170 2318
one double one local volunteer nominated
for an award rochford District Council's
windmill volunteer Trevor Rand was up
for yet another award for his work at
raley windmill the first annual share
volunteer awards for museums in the East
received an impressive 87 nominations
from 46 different museums around the
eastern region nominations were received
from museums of all sizes as the awards
scheme seeks to recognize the valuable
contribution that volunteers make to
museums and their communities trevor was
nominated in the category of going the
extra mile for the outstanding effort
and time he contributed to being the
volunteer coordinator during 2014 Simon
Floyd of share museums East said these
awards are an ideal chance to celebrate
the importance of volunteers to museums
showcase the range of roles that
volunteers undertake and demonstrate the
diversity of the people who offer their
time as volunteers in addition through
these awards share can highlight best
practice in both volunteering and
volunteer management the judging panel
sat in the middle of May and the winners
were announced that a celebration and
awards evening with drinks and canapes
on fourth of June at the Atheneum
embarrass and Edmonds there were joint
winners in Trevor's category from the
North Hartford sure museums service and
University of Cambridge museums rochford
districts summer holiday activity
program rochford District Council in
partnership with Fusion lifestyle
rochford extended services will be
delivering a range of sports and arts
activities during the summer holidays
including golf swimming basketball and
theatre workshops the main event of the
summer would be our annual free family
sports festival at Great Wakering
primary school on Thursday August the
20th from 12 noon to four p.m. various
sports and activities for children of
all ages and parents to try it's free of
charge and there is limited parking on
site for full details please download
the brochure which is now available at
WWE you k /o ledee activities to be
added to our email distribution list to
ensure you are the first to get future
holiday programs please call the
Rochford district and leisure team on 0
1 702 318 120 or email leisure at
Rochford garvey UK running has never
been so popular they say good things
were meant to be and that's certainly
the case with Hollywood's parkrun
hockley Woods Park run started on
februari the seventh this year and since
then 938 different runners including
participants from a 54 athletics clubs
have completed 2473 runs covering a
total distance of twelve thousand three
hundred and sixty five kilometers and
there have been 813 new personal bests
the run which starts in hockley woods
every saturday at 9am has attracted
runners from around the UK and abroad
and with the ever-changing environment
is a must do on the park run list not
that it's an easy course with the
undulating trails in the woods a real
challenge to the runners but having said
that gb athlete adam hickey flew round
the two lap course in 15 point 35
minutes setting the course record in
week six it really is a testament to
park run that this event along with
nearby events at Southend basildon
chelmsford and malden steadily grows in
number week on week parkrun organised
free week
five kilometer time runs around the
world they're open to everyone they're
free and are safe and easy to take part
in they're all run by a core team of
volunteers with runners receiving their
time position and park run history by
text and email usually by the time
they've got home for more information
please visit www our crew nor guk /
hockley woods fly-tipping fly-tipping is
the illegal dumping of rubbish
punishable by a maximum sentence of an
unlimited fine and five years
imprisonment on conviction you can help
prevent fly-tipping remember your waist
duty of care fly-tipping often occurs
when rogue waste carriers illegally dump
the waste that they collect to avoid
proper disposal fees and maximize their
profits unfairly undercutting legitimate
businesses you have a legal
responsibility or duty of care to make
sure that all wastes from your household
or business is disposed off correctly
it's you that could face prosecution and
a fine of up to 5,000 pounds if your
waste ends up fly tipped you can help to
prevent fly-tipping by taking the
following action for householders
whenever you arrange for anyone else to
dispose of your waist remember the scrap
code s suspect beware of rogue waste
carriers who dumped waste illegally if
in doubt don't let them take your waist
c4 check ask for their waste carriers
registration details you can check on
the environment agency website or by
calling 0370 850 6506 note down the
registration number of the vehicle used
to take your waste away all for
refuse refuse unsolicited offers always
carry out your own research and choose
who you want to take your waist away a4
ask ask questions ask what is going to
happen to your waist seek evidence that
it is going to be disposed of
appropriately a legitimate professional
waste carrier shouldn't object to being
asked reasonable questions and peepers
it p is for paperwork make sure you get
a proper invoice and receipt for your
waist and the advice for businesses is
if you give your business waste to
anyone other than a licensed waste
management company or legitimate
disposal site you must check that they
are a registered waste carrier check the
Public Register of waste carriers on
0370 850 6506 or online at WWF an agency
dot-gov dot uk' you must ensure that you
complete waste transfer notes relating
to all waste that comes from your
business you must keep these for a
period of two years failure to produce
waste transfer notes when asked by the
council or the environment agency is an
offence for which fixed penalty fines of
300 pounds can be issued parks and
woodlands a kaleidoscope of butterflies
a good spell of sunshine benefits
wildlife particularly insects for many
the star of the summer show will always
be the butterfly a delicate dancing fly
past seen on a sunny day is just the
final stage of a very tough and complex
for stage lifecycle known as complete
metamorphosis stage 1 the egg a
butterfly starts life is a very small
egg laid on or near to a leaf of its
favorite food plant peacock and red
admiral butterflies like stinging
nettles best stage to the law
caterpillar the eggs hatch and the tiny
caterpillar Z meet emerge their purpose
to eat and grow as fast as they can
increasing their body weight by 1000
times or more their skin does not
stretch so they grow by shedding the
outgrown skin several times while they
grow each molt is called an in star
stage 3 pupa chrysalis once they have
reached full length and weight they
transform themselves into a pupa and to
attach themselves to a leaf inside of
the pupa the caterpillar is changing
rapidly its body dish tissue becomes a
DNA and genetic rich fluid which
transforms through a process called
metamorphosis into completely new body
parts needed as an adult butterfly stage
for adult butterfly once the changing
process inside the pupil is complete the
butterfly emerges from the chrysalis the
wings which are covered in minut scales
giving the butterfly its individual
patterns and color are pumped full of
blood and within a few hours it takes
flight to find a mate in this final
stage of their lives adult butterflies
search for a mate and reproduce the
females lay their eggs and the
butterfly's life cycle starts all over
again why not plant your garden with
Nick to rich butterfly friendly plants
make sure you leave a few patches of
nettles for the hungry caterpillars tips
for spotting butterflies a warm calm day
between 11am and 2pm sunny sheltered
spots in woods parks and gardens and
some butterflies you may see this summer
are the peacock Red Admiral Hawley blue
large white comma speckled wood ringlets
and gatekeeper district Pet Sematary
offers peaceful final resting rochford
district council would like to remind
residents that the cherry orchard
jubilee country park in rochford now has
a dedicated area for people looking for
a final resting place for their pets the
country park offers grieving pet owners
a beautiful and tranquil area of the 200
acre park for the ashes of their beloved
animals count
I have a Glen chairman at Rochford
District Council recently laid her dog's
ashes in the cemetery planting a tree
and marking location with a memorial
plaque she said the death of a pet is a
sad and heartbreaking time it has been a
real comfort to know that my pet has
been laid to rest in such a beautiful
and peaceful location and that I can
come and visit the spot whenever I want
your local councillors there are 39
councillors representing 19 Ward's or
areas of the district following the
local elections in May the political
groupings within the district council
are as follows 28 conservative for Green
Party and Rochford residents three you
Kip to Liberal Democrats one non-group
conservative and one Labour councillor
contact details for your essex county
councillors are available at WWE 6 gov
UK or by phoning Oh 1 2 4 5 430 481 and
these are your local councillors
ashington and canoe 'don g io know you
and TG cut more both conservative
bawling and sutton MJ steptoe
conservative downhill and roar earth see
I black and ra autumn both lib dem foul
nests and great wakering NJ hook way you
Kip cg segars conservative and BJ
Wilkins conservative Grange JC Burton
you Kip JR Lumley conservative for Hawk
well north the counselors are la butcher
and je McPherson both conservative hawk
well south mweb and counselor mrs.
Heather Glynn who is the council's
chairman this year both of them are from
the Conservative Party in Hawk well
South jr f Mason and
m Mason green and Rockford District
residents group hotly central KH hudson
see a western and BTW Hazelwood or
conservatives hotly north mr carter
conservative hotly west em Maddox
conservative and in Harbridge em hoi and
d hoy green and Rockford District
residents group and AV hail conservative
in lodge Ward D Merrick and IH Ward both
conservative Railly central mhm Spencer
and mrs. C ero both conservative in
rochford GA Lucas Gill conservative k j
gordon non-group conservative and JH
Gibson labor Swain Park Ji Montford and
mrs. CA pavlin both conservative Trinity
DJ sparing conservative and J hater you
Kip in weekly ward JD Griffin
conservative and jl Norman conservative
councils vice-chairman in White House
are our dre and SP Smith both
conservative meet the new chairman for
the second time I am very honored to be
invited to become chairman of Rochford
District Council for 2015 to 16 as many
of you may remember i was chairman in
1995 296 and now so many years later
again i have been the representative for
hawk will east and south since 1990 and
thank you to the residents for
continuing to elect me how the area of
Rochford district has changed in those
26 years many areas of Greenbelt are now
very pleasant different types of local
housing estates with their communities
making the district a very vibrant price
to live in schools parks clubs etc are
in each parish and
town area for all to enjoy I have lived
in the rockville area since 1954 my
children and grandsons all attended
local schools and now they reside here
with their families my husband and I
served on hawk or parish council for
over 20 years a Magnolia nature reserve
and park of the pride and joy of hawk
will perish having served on various
fundraising projects at South in
hospital and when the foundation trust
was formed I have served on that too
over the years Rochford District
Council's forward thinking has changed
its various committee and officers
structures to bring it up to the very
modern style of working today my charity
is training guide dogs for the deaf and
disabled and blind there are many local
residents who benefit from these
wonderful animals should you wish to
support the fundraising with either a
gift or money I would be pleased to
accept it and assure you it will be put
to good use I look forward to meeting as
many of you as I can this year and if we
would like to invite me to any event
that you are holding please contact lynn
Rackley civic officer the council
offices in South Street Rochford
postcode is SS for one BW you can call
her on Oh 170 2318 144 or email her on
lick Lynn dot Rackley at Rochford guru K
my thanks to everyone and that's from
councillor Heather Glynn chairman
honours districts superheroes this mace
or Rochford district councils former
chairman councillor june Lumley host a
very special evening to pay tribute to
individuals and groups who make a big
difference to the district each year
rochford District Council asks for
nominations for the Citizen of the Year
awards which are held to recognize and
acknowledge residents in our district
your ball hard work and outstanding
achievements the judging panel was
inundated with entries and read
exceptional stories from nominees of all
ages who contribute to our community in
lots of different ways
winner of Citizen of the Year award was
presented to Carl cadman Carl is race
director for the Kirsty five race an
annual event which has raised nineteen
thousand five hundred pounds for
Macmillan nurses and Southend hospital
trust since 2012 working with Rochford
District Council Carl has helped to
bring Park runs to the district 5
kilometer runs that take place every
saturday morning in hockley woods
Carly's also a join in local leader for
Essex encouraging and placing new
volunteers in sports clubs in the area
he is a UK Athletics l2 endurance coach
and England's athletics race adjudicator
he also sits on the Essex athletics
Network his dedication and passion makes
a real difference to the local community
the winner of the young citizen of the
year award was Carl Beavis Carl works
extremely hard in the community giving
up his days off to teach boxing too
vulnerable young people teaching
discipline self-discipline and most of
all respect for themselves and others
Carl has also worked with young mums on
a very tight budget to teach them how to
cook from scratch using fresh
ingredients the winner of the charitable
support award was Carol Warren carol has
been involved with a hawk lien hawk well
old people's day centre for 25 years and
it's partly down to her tremendous
dedication that this very worthwhile
charity has been able to be kept going
on top of this Carol still makes time to
look after her family and previously
spent many years supporting and
fundraising for the first Hawk well
Scout Group the judging panel was so
impressed with the quality of the
nominations in the community spirit
category that they were unable to come
to one overall win
therefore the joint winners of the
community spirit category were Patricia
byford and Mike Cooper Patricia byford
has volunteered with the Rayleigh
Rochford and district association
voluntary service revs for many years
taking a lead role in the Rabs families
in need appeal Patricia raises over a
thousand pounds every year in cash gen8
donations and arranged the distribution
of over a hundred food parcels to under
privileged families and elderly
residents in the district Mike Hooper
has been a long-term member and
supporter of Rochford district
neighborhood watch for many years acting
as a street coordinator management
committee member and since 2010 has been
the chairman during his tenure
membership of Neighborhood Watch in the
district has almost doubled mike is
always willing to organize or
participate in community events
including the council's cope events
aimed at older residents of the district
crucial crew delivering to school
children by tagging sessions at many
locations and community safety events
after presenting the awards Rochford
district councils former chairman
councillor june Lumley said everyone who
was nominated for an award is a winner
the Citizen of the Year awards are the
perfect way to pay tribute to all the
people who make such a difference to
their communities during my year as
chairman I have had both the privilege
and the pleasure of visiting a huge
number of local community and voluntary
groups and I'm humbled and amazed by the
work these people do the talent that
they have and the generosity they show
to others across the district I would
like to thank all those who took the
time to complete nomination forms and
who brought the hard work dedication and
commitment of these people to our
attention at the council our vision is
to make the district
place that provides opportunities for
the best possible quality of life for
all who live work and visit here all of
the winners and nominations this year
represent and support that vision I hope
that by celebrating and recognizing
those who are making such a difference
to our district that it will encourage
them and give further opportunities so
that they can continue making such a
positive difference to their communities
sing-along Greece at Rochford District
Council's open-air cinema grab a blanket
pack a picnic and get down to swain park
on Saturday August the 15th for the
latest in the open air cinema events now
is the chance to sing along to grease
the musical movie age rating PG and
enjoy the great outdoors these evening
events hosted by essex outdoor cinema
have already taken place at hockley
woods and offer everyone the chance of a
great night out at some of the most
impressive surroundings in the district
a bar and food outlet will open to offer
those who require refreshments the
chance to eat and enjoy a true cinematic
experience with the difference Rockford
District Council's portfolio holder for
the community counselor June Lumley said
this is al fresco dining and
entertainment at its best and shows just
how diverse Rochford is both in terms of
the environments we have at our
fingertips and the array of artistic
endeavors we encourage Greece is a
classic of its kind which in the height
of the Great British summer is a must
for family and friends alike let's just
hope the greased lightning appears only
on the big screen please note that open
air cinema venues are subject to
capacity restrictions and entrance
without a pre-booked ticket is not
guaranteed please pre booked your ticket
and avoid arrive early to avoid
disappointment tickets for all showings
are 12 pounds and the gates open at
seven pm and for up-to-date information
and to book
your tickets visit w WX outdoor cinema
com renters rights greater protection
from rogue landlords and letting agents
rochford and rayleigh Citizens Advice
Bureau is participating in a national
campaign to improve standards in the
private rented sector in the last year
more than 80,000 people came to Citizens
Advice nationally suffering problems
with their privately rented homes which
represents a six percent increase on the
previous year our clients are mostly
commonly hit with issues caused by rogue
landlords or letting agents we are
campaigning to put an end to the
following problems for private renters
both locally and nationally which cause
undue strain on thousands of people each
year bad behavior by a landlord or
letting agent such as renting out poorly
maintained properties failing to make
repairs or harassing tenants inflated
fees charged by letting agents for basic
services misleading advertisements by a
landlord or letting agent eviction at
short notice so far this year Citizens
Advice has successfully campaigned to
stop retaliatory eviction of tenants who
complain about poorly maintained
properties and we would like to continue
to build upon this achievement
throughout 2015 if you are currently
experiencing problems caused by a
landlord or letting agent and would like
free independent impartial and
confidential advice please contact
Rochford and rayleigh Citizens Advice
Bureau Rochford office is in back lane
Rochford SS 41 a why opening hours
tuesdays and thursdays from ten a.m. to
2pm the rayleigh office is
situated in the Civic sweet hockley road
rayleigh SS 680 be opening hours are
mondays thursdays and fridays from ten
a.m. to 2pm you can telephone 03 double
44 double 70 80 8 monday to friday
between 10am and 4pm you can email w WH
foods cabg OG UK online advice including
web chat monday to friday 9am to 5pm
www.vitac.com unity messaging ECM
enables everyone in essex to receive and
share the very latest information about
crime and community safety in their
local area everyone who registers for
ECM will receive accurate and up-to-date
information crime prevention advice and
notifications from essex police officers
essex watch liaison officers and other
key partners such as neighborhood watch
about crime and community safety issues
in their local area you can register at
ww essex community messaging dot org
users will be able to select the
information they want to receive
including issues they may have a
particular interest in such as scams
internet crime or rural crime they will
also be able to choose whether to
receive this information via email text
or voice message do you have a
brownfield site that you'd like to
promote for development the council has
started work on a new local plan which
will ensure that a plan covering at
least 15 years is in place as part of
this it is important for us to find out
where there are available sites in the
district which may be suitable for
development in the future whether it is
for new homes open space or land for
education or employment use for example
we are therefore calling on those with
an interest in land in the district to
promote their site through the call for
sites we are particularly keen to
identify land that has previously been
developed brownfield which may have
become available since 2011 the
information gathered through the call
for sites will be used to inform the
evidence base to support the new local
plan which will assist us in addressing
national planning policy requirements in
particular meeting housing need the new
local plan however it is at a very early
stage and it is not guaranteed that any
additional land will be required to be
allocated for the development of any use
to find out more on information on the
call for sites or to promote a site
visit w WAW k and follow the call for
sites link under in focus alternatively
contact the planning policy team by
email planning dot policy at Rochford
govt UK or phone 0170 2 3 18 19 1 speak
up on elder abuse helpline and online
reporting form earlier this year saw the
launch of a new elder abuse helpline
powered by Crimestoppers elder abuse is
a national problem it's not specific to
Essex but agencies across the county
felt that it was an issue that needed to
be addressed and have been proactive in
the setting up of this helpline in 2013
to 14 in Essex there are almost 1,500
cases of reported abuse which involved
individuals over the age of 65 the free
24-7 reporting line is anonymous but
callers have the option to leave their
details if they wish and aims to
encourage members of the public to
report any incident of elder abuse
whether it's in a care home hospital or
in the individual's own home cause will
be taken by call agents from the Crime
Stoppers contact centre who have been
trained on how to take calls on elder
abuse this ensures they ask the right
questions to gain as much in
formation as possible the information
will be passed to the relevant local
authorities safeguarding officers if a
criminal offense has taken place
information will also be passed to the
relevant police force and the number for
the reporting line is a 800 oh 3 to 7 64
for further information can be found on
ww essex SI b org UK be sure at the door
the rogue trader campaign the Community
Safety Partnership is supporting the
campaign launched by essex Trading
Standards Essex Police & age UK Essex
earlier this year with regard to rogue
traders trading standards have made a
fridge magnet which is being distributed
to elderly people as these are
particularly vulnerable to Road traders
by community agents Age UK staff PCSOs
and the district community safety team
with some advice about how to avoid
falling prey to rogue traders and about
how to hire a genuine trader the magnets
are also available from libraries and GP
surgeries the aim is also to alert
relatives to the rogue trader issue so
they can direct their relation to
reputable traders that can be found by
either going online at www buy with
confidence go UK or by calling 0845 40
40 50 six peeps afeeee Rochford District
Council's keep safe scheme is set to be
rolled out in great wakering over the
summer and is now successfully up and
running in rayleigh hockley and Rochford
following the initial launch in the
district in rayleigh last October the
keep safe scheme aims to help vulnerable
people living within the district feel
safer and is already available in over a
hundred venues across essex the purpose
of the keep safe scheme is to provide
places in the town where an older person
who feels unwell upset or disorientated
can go to a keep safe venue and ask for
help
to contact a family member friend or
carer local venues identified as safe
places provide free access to use of a
telephone or will make a call on behalf
of someone producing their keep safe
card rochford District Council's
assistant director for community and
Housing Services Jodi bridge said the
keep safe scheme provides vulnerable
people with a safe place where they can
seek help should they encounter a
problem while they're out in the
district I'm very pleased to confirm
that following very successful launches
in rayleigh hockley and Rochford it will
now also be available in great wakering
for more information about the scheme
call Rochford District Council's
Community Safety scheme on 0 1 702 318
112 or visit the council's website w wh
0 Gav UK / keep safe hoax and scams are
now a daily occurrence thieves are
targeting us from every direction for
the latest scams see the Essex
neighborhood watch website www essex n
HW org UK some of the scams recently
mentioned our courier fraud online
auction scam phishing scam computer
fault scam hoax parcel delivery scan to
name just a few the courier fraud is
where members of the public are cold
called by fraudsters posing as bank
officials or police officers who asked
for your bank details such as your
account number and security details
leads fraudsters are always finding new
ways to deceive you and obtain the
details they need to access your bank
accounts the current trend is to change
the number they're calling from to match
the fraud reporting telephone number
that can be found on the back of your
bank cards this number is programmed to
show up on your caller ID display and is
designed to make you think it really is
the bank calling you remember do not
give your bank details to anyone and
genuine caller will never ask for these
take all necessary steps to assure
yourself that the caller is genuine
before you discuss anything with them
helping you with funding did you know
that the council has a special facility
in place that can help organizations
such as community and voluntary groups
sports and other clubs schools social
enterprises and small businesses to
search across a huge range of funding
sources free the council has joined
forces with grant net to provide a
searchable database of funding
opportunities ranging from European
funds through to Lottery awards and
charitable trusts grant net is
completely free to use and is available
by clicking WWE r hf a govt UK forward
slash grant search it's a really simple
system to use you just register your
details and obtain a password in order
to search the system for funds
appropriate to your project the
council's community planning officer
Andrew lowing said this is an excellent
service and provides access to a wide
and varied range of funding bodies it
can be time-consuming finding the right
source of funding for your project and
the benefit of this service is that it
provides information on the full range
of UK and european union support
provision in a single searchable
database suitable for all types of
organizations for more information or if
you have any questions about grant net
you can contact andrew lowing on 0170
231 8061 for more in-depth funding
advice you can contact the rayleigh
Rochford and district association for
voluntary service ravs by telephone on
01 268
double seven 2796 carers choices elderly
and dementia daycare center Cara's
choices is a local charity offering
support to carers it recently moved to a
brand new daycare facility based in
thunders Lee and they are eager to
attract more residents from the Rochford
district to use their service offering
specialized care from trained support
workers the program of activities is
offered which includes music crafts and
exercises and nutritious hot meal snacks
and tea and coffee are provided in this
stimulating environment brand new
refurbished facilities and they open
saturdays to an outside space and
central location with parking the center
/ prides itself on being safe and secure
providing essential respite breaks at
for carers for further information
please call Oh 1268 double eight double
130 or email care at kara's choices org
this new center is situated at the White
House kill road benfleet essex ss7 1bu
for sat nav ss7 1tf and is the building
behind Castle Point council offices now
here are some details of some local
clubs and groups and the rayleigh
library writers group the friendly group
of local writers and poets who are
looking to recruit new members they meet
on the second thursday of each month at
raley library room to from three to five
pm and for thursday of each month at 36
Cheapside east rayleigh from 715 to 915
p.m. the cost is a pound to cover light
refreshments and you can contact jane on
0126 878 5427 or Bob on 0126 878 double
496 or email WR French at talktalk net
and the roach arc
Group caters for all abilities at this
friendly club with good lighting and
facilities and a variety of media it's
on Wednesday evenings from 732 930 p.m.
at some Teresa's Churchill ashington
road the post cody's ss4 1rf there are
reasonable fees applied for details on
request from debs on 07 9077 14 double 0
2 or John on 079 double 3263 930 or at
their website www a chart group WI XCOM
the recycled teenagers forum is a
friendly and welcoming group providing
encouragement and support for people
aged 14 / to access activities and day
trips at affordable prices it's on
fridays from 11 till 11 45 a.m. the WI
hall in rochford square there are
various prices so contact them for
membership and trip information on 0170
261 double 619 oro double 79 220 double
724 or recycled teenagers at live co uk
or WWE cycle teenagers or Guk and
hopefully jazz records society listen to
jazz music you can bring your own music
or listen to others it's on the third
thursday of each month from a 732 10pm
at hogwarts village hall and it costs
three pound per night for more
information contact ken mizzen on 0170
2203 437 befriending castlepoint
association of voluntary services are
looking for brief ending volunteers in
the district summer is the hardest time
to recruit volunteers due to the good
weather but those that are lonely are
still lonely even when the sun is
shining contact Vitti Vickie Hilton on 0
1 2 68 638 416
and community agents essex an innovative
new partnership supporting older people
and their informal carers community
agents essex are passionate about trying
to contact those hard to reach people
that may be housebound or isolated
contact mary anne patterson on 0 1 376
5743 41 or email marion patterson at cas
6 oq k events come along to rayleigh
horticultural societies autumn show on
Sunday September 6th between 2 and 4 30
p.m. it's at the mill arts & Events
Center bellingham Lane rayleigh SS 67 ed
and it costs 1 pounds for adults and
accompany children are admitted free you
can contact pat hill by email pd hill 10
@ hotmail.com or go to the website WWE
le horticultural society co uk and at
the roach art group autumn exhibition
there will be art demonstrations
throughout the day and refreshments
available it's on Saturday September the
26th between 10am and 4pm at Rochford WI
hall west street rochford SS 41 aah and
it's free contact Deb's on 07 9077 14
double O 2 or John 079 double 3263 930
or visit the website w WH er up wi XCOM
activities rayleigh town history walks
there conducted by a representative from
the National Trust Rayleigh mount
committee every saturday until the end
of sep tember at 3pm they meet at raley
windmill and it costs to pounds per
person rayleigh windmill exhibitions
will take place on
the second floor of the windmill during
the 2015 season visitors can also meet
the artists who will be there with their
exhibition during opening hours it's
open from the 28th of march to the 30th
of sep tember on wednesdays from ten
a.m. to 1pm and saturdays and sundays
from one to four p.m. the windmills in
bellingham lane rayleigh the entry is
free although a minimum 1 pound donation
per person is encouraged if you'd like
further information wwh Vidovic a
forward slash windmill for more
information about the exhibitions and
dates that the windmill is closed for
private events southend airports Vulcan
plane you can visit the Vulcan at london
Southend Airport sundays from ten a.m.
to four p.m. and it will cost three
pounds fifty for the over 16's cockpit
visits cost three pounds each regardless
of age and sing along greece on saturday
the 15th of august gates open at seven
p.m. at swain park the tickets are 12
pounds each and to book visit w WS
except door cinema com and finally
council and committee meetings all
meetings will take place at the Civic
sweet to hotly road rail ESS 680 be
starting at seven thirty p.m. and for
information call member services on 0 1
702 318 140 the review committee meet on
sep tember the 8th the executive
committee September the 9th development
committee August the 20th and sep tember
the 17th and the Audit Committee
September the 15th Rochford district
matters is designed and published by
rockford district council the telephone
number for the council is 0 1 702 546
366 the magazine is printed
by Morton print--limited 01 50 75 2 3 4
5 6 and this recording has been produced
by volunteers from the rayleigh Rochford
and castlepoint talking newspaper